[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren führte nach dem tag der
schlagzeilen macht heute mit dabei die
bundesvorsitzende der
familienunternehmer sana wo ist also ist
unternehmerin sitz im aufsichtsrat
einnehmen und ist beirätin der deutschen
bank das wirtschaftsmagazin capital
zählt sie zu den top 40 und 40 talenten
und sah damit am woche in dem
bundespräsidenten mitwählen neben ihr
philipp reisner hätten wir gäste
kategorien hierbei fielen nach acht
würde hier geltend gäste von morgen denn
erst den landesvorsitz der jungen union
hamburg und stellvertretender
landesvorsitzender der cdu an meiner
seite die welt journalist und autor in
seine gast 2012 würde sie als spd
kandidat ist oberbürgermeister von kiel
wird und auch spannend sind promovierte
über kinderliteratur last but not least
der leiter von unserem parlamentsbüro
ralf schuler ich freue mich immer ganz
besonders wenn er hier ist es nicht nur
einer der besten familien polizisten des
landes sondern auch sehr pointiert und
meine stadt mein name ist mensch und ich
freue mich sehr dass ich den anfang
machen darf heute möchte ich meiner
freude ausdruck verleihen dass immer
mehr bundesländer in deutschland die
strenge zweijährige im ein slapshot ohne
impfausweis ist wieder möglich endlich
es ist der erste schritt richtung
freiheit und dass diese spalterischen
maßnahmen endlich enden länder wie
schweden haben die menschen nie
gespalten aber wir haben es getan und
als gesellschaft einfach hingenommen ja
gar die ausgrenzung wo dir noch von
teilen der bevölkerung als solidarischer
akt gefeiert ich frage mich seit monaten
welcher politiker kann diese
spalterischen maßnahmen noch
verantworten im blick auf die aktuelle
aus italiens rate ist es besonders
bizarr die regierung darf in sich länger
als maßnahmen zwingen und der
zweijährige rums ist ein guter erster
schritt
janina ich muss da gleich einsteigen
weil ich wirklich wichtig finde dass du
dieses thema heute mitgebracht hast ich
kann mich noch sehr gut daran erinnern
genau einem jahr sind wir mit den jungen
unternehmern force
wirtschaftsministerium gezogen und haben
demonstriert für eine öffnung strategie
das ist ein jahr her und heute
diskutieren wir immer noch darum unter
im handel hat wirklich die letzten zwei
jahre massiv unter diesen
einschränkungen gelitten und deswegen
muss jetzt auch die öffnung kommen wir
brauchen auch in anderen bereichen eine
öffnung strategie schauen wir uns die
kitas an die schulen wir brauchen ein
planen es kann nicht sein dass die
regierung erst praktisch reagiert wenn
der öffentliche druck zu groß wird
deswegen bin ich voll bei dir wir müssen
öffnen wir müssen diesen massiven
wirtschaftlichen schaden jetzt auch
auffangen verdienende und es war ja
nicht nur ein schaden also natürlich ist
der wirtschaftliche schaden groß aber
der schaden für die menschen die zwei
gehen nicht entsprechend konnten aus
welchen gründen auch immer war auch sehr
groß und es ging dabei ja von anfang an
und das ist eigentlich politisch so gar
nicht akzeptabel um schikane umerziehung
wenn ich also man sollte also wir haben
ja vorher als es noch gar keinen
impfstoff gab auch alle an masken und
tests geglaubt und gehofft dass die
wirken und was aussagen können und man
kann überhaupt nicht verstehen warum
machten und tests nicht sozusagen bei
gesunden menschen wog ein
krankheitsverdacht vor nicht völlig
reichen sollen um auch ein schuhgeschäft
zu betrieb ich finde ja man müsste
einfach eine grundsätzliche sichtung all
der maßnahmen die inzwischen aufgelaufen
sind vornehmen zweig ist ein punkt ist
es ja nicht einsehbar dass man im
gewerbegebiet wenn man zu kaufland geht
einfach rein geht mit seiner maske und
nebenan im schuh center wo man zu zweit
auf 300 quadratmetern steht da zeigt man
vorher sein seinen impfnachweis aber es
ist auch sonst einiges aufgelaufen also
seltsamen hotel regeln wo alle geimpft
sind dreifach gern auch das personal
mann mit der maske rein kommt und dann
trotzdem noch zwischen eine
plexiglasscheibe hat und beim frühstück
sich plastik an zu ansehen und die
minibar ist leer und die minimoys ist
natürlich leer salzstreuer gibt es nicht
damit man sie nicht anfassen kann und in
stadien sitzen dann 3000 leute obwohl
60.000 reinpassen alle auf einer seite
dicht beieinander da fragst du dich auch
was soll das also es ist schon sehr
kurios und da könnte man einfach mal
ordentlich ausmisten und das sinnlose
weglassen und dann ging es schon viel
besser aber er heißt als politiker sind
ja politiker von der union die union hat
ja auch vieles mitgetragen unter anderem
mehrere umgesetzt aber immer
durchgesetzt ja bei im amt und meine
frage an sie es wie kann denn ein
politiker die maßnahmen gerade ob noch
verantworten mit blick auf die aktuelle
aus der realisierung rate ich muss sagen
ich finde das sollte der politik doch
gerade wirklich jetzt langsam wirklich
langsam wird's ja ein bisschen bizarr
oder ich glaube das ist der
entscheidende punkt was herr schuler
gesagt hat dass die maßnahmen am ende
gut begründet sein müssen und sinn
machen müssen damit sie auch akzeptiert
werden sie dürfen auch begründet ja das
ist es eben also zum eintreffen sind
nicht widersprüchlich sein und zum
anderen war die begründung immer dass
die überlastung der intensivstation und
erkranken hoyzer droht und wenn das
nicht mehr der fall ist wo von immer
mehr krankenhäuser ärzte berichten auch
henrik strikt hat das heute noch mal
gesagt dann kann man nicht jetzt auf wie
es der gesundheitsminister tut auf
andere begründung plötzlich abheben
sondern man muss sagen wir haben immer
gesagt diese einschränkung gibt es wegen
der überlastung der krankenhäuser wenn
das nicht mehr droht dann müssen wir
auch locker und da müssen wir eine klare
lockerungs perspektive aufzeichnen das
sagen auch immer mehr virologen und da
kann man nur sagen herr lauterbach
listen todes 1 wobei die union natürlich
das problem hat ganz heftig bei der
impfpflicht mit gerührt zu haben und
sich da voll mit auf den zug gesetzt zu
haben auch die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht mit beschlossen zu haben und
jetzt macht sich so langsam wieder vom
acker völlig zu recht wie ich finde
trotzdem habe ich nie verstanden warum
die union so auf dem impfpflicht fahrt
gewesen ist das erbe der kanzlerin kann
es ja nicht allein gewesen sein was man
da verwalten wollte denn eines ist doch
klar wir haben im laufe der pandemie
immer wieder gesehen dass unsere
einsichten in das wirken des impfstoffs
aber auch in das verhalten des virus
sich zum teil von woche zu woche
geändert haben und jetzt eine pflicht zu
beschließen für eine zeit jetzt soll es
im herbst soll man die auf vorrat
beschließen von der wir nicht wissen
welches virus dank kassiert ob der
impfstoff noch wirkt finde ich einfach
völlig sinnlos wobei das impfen ja
gerade der weg raus ist aus den
maßnahmen die sie ja auch gerade beklagt
haben und das ist ja auch was wir ganz
stark aus der wirtschaft wird aber bei
der akn gericht weiter besuchen sind zum
beispiel wenn ich jetzt feststellen dass
der impfstoff schützt mich nicht ich
kann mich infizieren es schützt aber
auch nicht davor dass ich das virus
weiter gebe das heißt der effekt der
mobile patient soll geschützt werden der
wirt der tritt gar nicht ein
ich musste dann auch noch wieder testen
dann wäre aber der test eigentlich das
wichtige und und nicht so sehr im trend
ist nur um die vermeidung ganz kurz es
geht ja nicht nur um die vermeidung von
ansteckungen sondern eben darum den
effekt zu erreichen der sich jetzt hier
abzeichnet dass eben die krankenhäuser
nicht mehr so überlastet werden und das
ging ich am ende nur hin mit der im
pflege- oder mit mit der impfung so und
das ist dann so not da muss man eben
gucken wie wirkt der impfstoff wie ist
die entwicklung deswegen finde ich die
idee auf eurer das zu machen und
konkrete bellaguarda häusern das
pflegesystem und das gesundheitssystem
in deutschland sind nicht marode ist das
gab es auch schon vor corona dass ärzte
zeitung auch gewarnt haben dass die
intensiv station volllaufen das hat
krone er nicht erfunden oder nein sicher
nicht ich meine wir sind im
internationalen vergleich glaube ich gar
nicht so schlecht aufgestellt was
reserven bei intensivstationen angeht
aber ich denke haben alle gelernt in der
pandemie jetzt sondern für so eine
extremsituation hat es offensichtlich
nicht gerade intensiv band quote der
welt und ehrlicherweise muss man auch
sagen die ganze
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite die sollte ja genau diesen
zweck dienen die überlastung zu
verhindern ist war der höchste wert von
koma patienten auf intensivstationen um
die 25 prozent er war also zu jedem
zeitpunkt selbst als es ganz schlimm war
in der zweiten welle insofern war dieses
argument von anfang an heike unter
verfassungsrechtlichen gesichtspunkten
und jetzt wird es jetzt wird es wirklich
absurd aber ich aber an diesem punkt
fehlt mir tatsächlich auch noch die
strategie wenn ich mit pflege
unternehmen spreche das thema
pflegekräfte und bei den einrichtungen
jetzt die impfpflicht kommen soll wir
haben jetzt schon das thema zu wenig
pflegekräfte was passiert also ich hab
mit einem pflegeunternehmen erst vor
kurzem gesprochen der mir sagt 40
prozent meines pflegepersonals ist nicht
geimpft was mache ich jetzt wenn dieser
impfpflicht kommt dann fehlen uns noch
mehr pflegekräfte weg da brauchst auch
eine strategie der regierung wie das
ganze funktionieren soll das noch die
praktisch betreuung von den älteren von
den pflegenden gewährleistet ist es ein
großes thema ja es gibt eine mindest
fachkraftquote in pflegeheimen das
müssen approbierte pfleger seien und
wenn mir von denen eine bestimmte zahl
von der stange gehen dann kann ich die
ganze einrichtung nicht machen das ist
einfach das problem und das ist
eigentlich auch der punkt den söder
sieht wenn er sehenden auges in ein
pflegenotstand reihen marschiert dann
selbst dann lieber die irgendwie ja das
kann ich ganz gut verstehen auch wenn
allen kehlen haben wir den mops
beschlossen zehn mann auch durch das
kann ja nicht das motto sein also da bin
ich auch total mal also ich bin ja nicht
der größte markus söder fan ich halte
ihn ja für den populisten aber und für
so ein pseudo popstar ist nicht mein
lieblings politiker aber ich muss sagen
ich finde das gut und ich werde jeden
politiker an diesem tisch feiern sagt
okay wir machen sind es doch anders wir
machen die amtlich nicht weil das dürfen
wir können ja nicht sagen nein halt
weitern im harten kurs fest und damit
ihr keine umfaller seit ist doch super
wenn die sich jetzt ein bisschen
dahingehend ändern dass mit der
impfpflicht wie wahrscheinlich ist es
denn eigentlich noch er heißt er dass
sie kommt wie sehen sie das eigentlich
persönlich sind sie für die uns nicht
also meine persönliche meinung ist dass
es wahrscheinlich wenn es so bleibt wie
jetzt er nicht kommt wenn man sich
anguckt wie die verläufe sind bei omi
kronen wenn man sich anschaut das sagt
ja auch henrik strikt wie der impfstoff
wirkt eben dass er nicht verhindert dass
man sich auch weiter ansteigt das sind
glaube ich alles faktoren die man eben
berücksichtigen muss nur wir wissen es
eben heute noch nicht wie das im herbst
aussieht vielleicht kommt eine neue
variante vielleicht kommt neuer
impfstoff vielleicht entwickeln sich die
dinge anders als wir denken das haben
wir in der pandemie mehrfach erlebt und
bevor wir in den nächsten lockdown
müssen und die wirtschaft ja auch
riesige schäden nimmt das bedroht auch
lebensgrundlagen und so weiter und so
fort jetzt müssen wir als erster mensch
haben es ja eigentlich nicht so viel
gebracht haben als es gab jetzt auch der
studie wieder aus amerika gezeigt hat
die lok dort haben ja gar nicht so viel
gebracht im kampf gegen das
infektionsgeschehen na ja ich glaube
schon dass man auch in anderen ländern
sieht dass es zum teil deutlich größere
belastungen der intensivstation gab
darum ging es ja und ich finde schon
also wenn ich jetzt ein autounfall habt
dann will ich nicht irgendwie verrecken
müssen nur weil irgendwer seine maske
nicht tragen wollte und die
intensivstation blockiert so die frage
ist gibt es diesen zusammenhang und wenn
wir jetzt sehen dass die intensivstation
eben nicht überfüllt sind dann muss man
auch die maßnahmen hinterfragen und kann
nicht jetzt auf andere faktoren
plötzlich abstellen und sagen wir machen
weiter die unionsfraktion wird ja morgen
einen corona impfpflicht vorsorge
gesetzentwurf beraten in interner
sitzung nächsten nächste woche zur
disposition stellen da will man
allerdings nur die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen für eine mögliche
impfpflicht besprechen so dass man
gewappnet ist für die
ausführungsbestimmungen usw alles
weitere muss dann natürlich vor ort
geregelt werden du weißt ja gar nicht ob
jetzt eine pflicht beschließen für die
dritte vierte impfung oder für ein ganz
neuen impfstoff oder wofür überhaupt
eigentlich also mal sehen was da
rauskommt das ist so ein bisschen
inzwischen weg aber ich glaube die nun
täte gut daran die
regierung auch kritisch bei der
impfpflicht zu begleiten das tun wir ja
auch ich meine dass er genau der punkt
eben den instrumentenkasten zu erweitern
deswegen war auch die abschaffung dieser
pandemischen lage von von nationaler
tragweite nicht richtig weil man eben
instrumentenkasten eingeschränkt hat und
jetzt geht's wieder
na ja die möglichkeit dass das schafft
ja nur die möglichkeiten für die
bundesländer eben einen
instrumentenkasten zu haben um möglichst
effektiv arbeiten zu können um eben
locker usw
aber die regierung muss jetzt mal ein
vorschlag machen wie man das praktisch
umsetzt das ist doch jetzt
leider nicht mehr unsere aufgabe das in
jedem detail vorzuschlagen sondern da
muss die regierung endlich mal aufwachen
aus ihrem dornröschenschlaf und meine
handel die bürger geschützt werden
müssen von der politik auch auf den rat
ich hab heute ganz toll philipp ihr job
mein kollege ist in schweden gewesen der
eine schalte gemacht die fand ich sehr
spannend da hat er nämlich gesagt die
menschen haben dort vor ort gesagt sie
haben maßnahmen vorgeschlagen bekommen
wurden aber nicht dazu gezwungen und er
ist für mich ein ganz schön gedanken
versteht es überhaupt der regierung noch
länger zu uns eigentlich zu zwingen
sachen umzusetzen sollten sie nicht
lieber mal jetzt vorschläge machen weil
das jetzt gerade die intensivstation
vollauf mit blick auf die aktuelle
hausse mit der regierungsrat das können
wir jetzt richtig aber das ist ja genau
was ich sagen das ist tatsächlich
aufgabe der regierung das dann auch zu
tun und diese grundlagen eben zu
erarbeiten die man dafür braucht es geht
darum werkzeuge zur verfügung zu haben
wenn es zum beispiel wieder eine neue
variante gebe oder die impfstoffe sich
nicht mehr als wirksam herausstellt und
das kann ja passieren ich hoffe es alles
nicht ich glaube auch nicht dass es
wahnsinnig wahrscheinlich ist aber für
den fall geht es darum instrumente zu
schaffen das ist die position der union
aber die regierung muss ja konkret sagen
was wie man es auch praktisch dann
unsere gäste interessant da hat corona
nicht als erstes aber auch corona wieder
ganz unterschiedliche mentalitäten in
den einzelnen ländern freigelegt weil im
juni in großbritannien da haben die
gerade ihre ihren freedom day
verschieben müssen weil die zahlen
wieder nach oben ging aber da haben sie
natürlich nicht die papst zu gemacht und
man sagen es weiter draußen und man ging
auch weiter shoppen ja das leben
verändern weil deswegen ja nicht wir
müssen jetzt da irgendwie sowas
verschieben die schweden haben auch da
eine anderen zusammenhalt ideen auch die
deutschen sind grundsätzlich so
strukturiert wenn ein problem erkannt
ist muss es gelöst werden absoluter und
wenn wir feststellen dass die dass die
verschuldung ein übel ist dann wird
jetzt angefangen zu sparen da sagt der
grieche natürlich ja gut dass er
grundsätzlich recht aber noch nicht
jetzt passt gerade nicht nächste woche
der da sind ganz unterschiedliche
mentalitäten und deshalb administrieren
wir auch so liebevoll durch bis ins
eigene wohnzimmer drei leute aus 15
haushalten unter 14 mit fußmatte oder
ohne das ist eine ganz komische
geschichte die wir glaube ich aus den
genen nicht so schnell rauskriegen eine
sache die politik ja vermutlich schon
verspielt er bei vielen bürgern ist das
vertrauen und damit kommen wir sie in
frage wir haben in ihrem thema ja ich
fürchte tatsächlich wir müssen wir haben
lange gebraucht und überhaupt mal klar
zu machen krone hat auch
gesellschaftliche nebenwirkungen also
werden lange sozusagen ausschließlich
auf das medizinische problem gstaad das
war am anfang sicher auch richtig aber
dann wohl irgendwann gemerkt für kinder
und jugendliche ist das nicht so gut gar
nicht zur schule zu gehen und nicht in
der uni sein zu können wenn man nur zu
hause wir haben gemerkt für die
wirtschaft ist das dann doch irgendwie
an problemen und für die kultur auch
wenn die monatelang also nach und lagen
kriterien geschlossen wird und nachdem
er anfänglich eine wahnsinns zustimmung
hatten zu reinen maßnahmen also bis zu
80 prozent fanden am anfang so den
harten kurs und jetzt wird was getan
weil es anders als in der
flüchtlingskrise 2005 die jetzt mal was
getan jetzt gibt konkrete maßnahmen
konkrete vorschriften super konstant
halten klasse das haben die deutschen
also in ihrer 150% mentalität begeistert
mitgemacht aber dann langsam schleicht
sich das natürlich doch ab dann leidet
man unter der widersprüchlichkeit und
man fängt an sich zu fragen gefällt es
manchen leuten vielleicht einfach zu gut
dass wir diesen zustand haben wo die
politik ja doch einen gewissen wie soll
ich sagen herablassend reform und im ton
entwickelt hat gegenüber dem bürger also
sozusagen also dann wenn ich dann die
diversen impfkampagnen und so denke dann
hatte ich doch häufig das gefühl dass
ich ihn auf kindergartenniveau
angesprochen zu werden inzwischen haben
wir eine situation da hat sich das
wirklich umgekehrt haben also eine
erschreckende umfrage
bearbeitet letzten woche für die welt 23
prozent der deutschen sehen sich nach
einer repräsentativen umfrage von insa
inzwischen auf dem weg in die diktatur
und kann man immer darüber reden darf
man das so fragen überhaupt wie wichtig
also wie wie ernst muss man diese
repräsentativen umfragen nehmen wir
nehmen sie in der regel schon relativ
ernst wenn wir versuchen herauszufinden
wie ist die stimmung im land und sie ist
ja auch sonst steckt 46 prozent sagen
nach einer yougov-umfrage man darf in
deutschland seine meinung nicht mehr
frei sagen und das ist findet sich
gerade an diesen kronor team das kennt
ja jeder aus dem freundeskreis auch also
wie hat da zum teil bis zur sache geht
und wie sehr das freundschaften auch auf
zerbrechen so ist dieses meinungs- thema
hatte einst war auch im vergangenen jahr
schon so die einst bacher haben auch
gefragt wie geht es ihnen jetzt mit
corona nach dieser langen zeit 83
prozent gesagt das gesellschaftliche
leben hat sich sehr verändert nicht zum
vorteil in deutschland 70 prozent haben
das jahr 22 schon komplett abgeschrieben
also erwarten von dem gar nichts mehr
und 60 prozent sagen die mir geht es
selber schlechter als vor beginn der
pandemie 1 prozent sagt es geht uns
besser und da möchte man jetzt gar nicht
populistisch und böse zuspitzenden
unterstellen aber man hat so ein
bisschen das gefühl der politikbetrieb
der läuft ja einfach weiter da finden
die veranstaltung statt da hat man seine
mitarbeiter da da ist eigentlich nichts
anders als sonst und ich glaube dass das
eine latent immer vorhandene gefahr von
entfremdung zwischen politischen betrieb
und normalen menschen mit einem normalen
leben doch noch weiter verschärft und an
dem punkt befinden wir uns jetzt aber
das ist glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger
punkt und ein trend der leider schon
länger am laufen ist die
allensbach-umfrage haben das vertrauen
in die institutionen der bundesrepublik
unter demokratie überhaupt schon relativ
lange immer wieder abgefragt und die
kurve ist stetig sinkt beziehungsweise
steigend was das misstrauen betrifft
norbert röttgen hat man von systemischer
erschöpfung gesprochen das hat beim bei
der flüchtlingskrise in den riesen
knacks bekommen weil man sagte plötzlich
gelten diese regeln nicht mehr und das
hat jetzt eben auch noch mal so einen
knacks bekommen und man hat den eindruck
als ob es wie so ein sediment sich da
immer wieder schichten darauf tragen
weil die leute sagen ja grundrechte dann
werden sie plötzlich abgeschafft weil es
gerade nicht passt das kann doch nicht
wahr sein und man hat auch inzwischen
den eindruck dass es einen bestimmten
typus politiker nicht nur herrn
lauterbach gibt die sich irgendwie in
die rolle des nothelfer verliebt haben
so nach dem motto lasst mich durch ich
bin arzt und werde ich gebraucht
und im prinzip nicht davon lassen können
man man ist da völlig fasziniert wenn
man immer wieder erklärt bekommt das
also noch die wand bevorsteht der strick
erklärt ganz gut dass der anstieg längst
gebrochen ist und eigentlich jetzt das
ganze ab fällt nein wir müssen noch
warten und es könnte immer noch
schlimmer kommen und wer weiß was im
herbst noch ist und das ist die
psychologische dimension die wir an
gespielt wird in dieser ganzen
geschichte und das macht mir schon
einige sorgen dass uns die leute von der
stange gehen die einfach sagen ja gut
also das land das ist es jetzt auch
nicht mehr und was die da machen da oben
das betrifft mich alles nicht man kriegt
das immer schwerer wieder
zusammengehören und es ist eben zutiefst
beunruhigend also wie sehr die
parlamente ihre verantwortung auch
abgegeben haben an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz an die
exekutive wie lässt sich dann doch
letzten endes das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit dem
verhältnismäßigkeit dem umgegangen ist
also das ja war ja praktisch dann doch
rückblickend zumindest an der katholisch
wie die
bundespräsidentin also gewählte gesunde
abgeordnete auf die tribüne des
bundestags verband und ihnen damit de
facto natürlich die freie ausübung ihres
mandats erschwert es also dass sowas
keinen aufschrei keinen größeren gibt
das erschüttert mich nachgerade und dann
natürlich sozusagen das also ob das nun
das lka und der gesundheitsminister
davon wusste oder nicht wusste ist es
eigentlich gleich schlimm also man
verändert man über nacht den genesenden
status von von sechs auf drei monate
übrigens zunächst mal nicht für
bundestagsabgeordnete dass auch ein ganz
schön starkes stück ist dann weiß man
nichts davon wie ja herr lauterbach also
so auch so also sehr improvisiert einmal
interessant improvisiert mit zahlen
nicht ob das darum geht wer da auf den
intensivstationen liegt dann wusste er
mal ganz genau das sind die 47 48 ring
ich kann mich erinnern dass wir also
viele kollegen verzweifelt recherchiert
haben um rauszukriegen liegt denn man
auf die selbst keiner aber er wusste ist
er wusste wie sehr die krankheit kindern
schadet obwohl das glaube ich immer noch
also
prozente sind und jetzt sie weiß ja dass
500 menschen am tag sterben werden wenn
wir jetzt also irgendwie eine eröffnungs
perspektive die unsere nachbarländer
alle machen veranstalten also ich glaube
das zehrt alles aus und am anfang haben
die leute das vielleicht auch nicht so
schwer genommen nach dem motto ich kann
ja noch einkaufen gehen also grundrechte
haben ja auch leider etwas sehr
abstraktes im listen die viel konkreter
fühlen und leben aber langsam summiert
sich das doch wir holen hier auch die
sicht der unternehmer wie geht's denn in
familienunternehmen diesem land aber
unternehmer generell die haben ja auch
so viele unternehmen in diesem land auch
selbstständige haben ja auch gelitten
vor allem auch natürlich dadurch dass
auch viele geschäfte eingebrochen
absolut also das thema vertrauen in die
politik spüre ich natürlich auch bei
unseren familienunternehmen dass da viel
verloren gegangen ist am anfang der
pandemie wusste niemand was auf uns
zukommt da hat man noch richtung
regierung geschaut da hat man auch
dieses pragmatische handeln am anfang
noch wirklich gut geheißen das hat uns
wirklich sehr gut gefallen man hat
geschaut wie können wir jetzt damit
umgehen
dann haben die unternehmer natürlich das
was die politik sagt verfolgt und auch
befolgt das heißt viel eigenkapital
investiert in corona schutzmaßnahmen
mitarbeitern und ins home office
geschickt geschaut dass die betriebe
weiter am laufen bleiben und nach ihr
jetzt mittlerweile zwei jahren sind
viele unternehmer 1 auch sehr frustriert
dass regel wirrwarr dass wir haben die
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen das
investierte eigenkapital da ist auch
wirklich viel ärger frust und verloren
gegangenes vertrauen das ist schon
wahnsinn und es ist schlimm zu sehen und
deswegen hoffe ich bzw es wird ein
großes stück arbeit sein als von seiten
der politik von seiten der regierung
dieses vertrauen auch wieder
herzustellen
ja also ich die die das problem ist ja
sozusagen unbestritten und ich glaube es
hat zwei komponenten jetzt gerade in der
korona entwicklung und einer krone ab
anämie das eine ist das ist einfach
widersprüchliche ansätze gab also ich
kann das nur aus hamburg da hat dann der
senat beschlossen dass man beim laufen
um die als darum maske tragen soll oder
auf der einen straße bis hausnummer 25
und danach nicht mehr man durfte ohnehin
nur bis 10 uhr laupichler ja es gab dann
wird doch immer nicht mehr joggen
zufällige uhrzeit
sitzen bank sitzen soll sich sportlich
betätigt viel harmonie war voll aber im
fussball steigen durfte man nicht gehen
das sind auch glaube ich so sachen das
ist gar nicht unbedingt böser wille
immer oder irgendwie ideologische
verblendung sondern einfach schlecht
gemacht der
das meine ich wo bleibt der aufschrei
bei der politik hat nicht wirklich ich
warte darauf dass ein junger politiker
in der runde sitzt und richtig sagen es
reicht aber die politik sagt immer ja
vielleicht war es falsch gemanagt muss
man danach ist also ehrlich man muss
doch auch mal sagen es reicht kein
politiker funktionen dank ist reicht
aber es reicht doch langsamer sich bei
den maßnahmen die ich gerade genannt
haben können wir das getan hamburg als
cdu und haben da auch sehr deutlich
gesagt das geht so nicht dass damit
zerstört man eben vertrauen so aber es
die bild greift dann auch gerne auf
andere dann zum teil eben nicht so aber
es ist natürlich wichtig dass das auch
angesprochen wird das ist ja auch unser
system das eben kritik geübt werden kann
dort wo sie dann berechtigt ist und am
ende gibt es in bayern aber ich würde
den zweiten aspekt auch noch mal nennen
wollen ganz wichtig ist und das
bestätigen ja auch mehrere umfragen dass
immer mehr leute angst haben das zu
sagen was sie denken und das hat viel
glaube ich mit politischer korrektheit
zu tun das war auch ganz stark in der
debatte um die migration da hat es mich
wahnsinnig gestört egal was man gesagt
hatte man musste immer tapsen gerade
wenn man auch irgendwie einer politik
und öffentlichkeit unterwegs war habe
ich mich persönlich auch zum teil
wirklich eingeschränkt gefühlt weil man
vernünftige position hat oder ebenfalls
selber auch davon überzeugt dass es geht
gar nicht darum irgendwie
ausländerfeindlich zu sein oder so aber
einfach auch eine kritische position zu
haben zu dem was passiert ist und dann
zum teil gibt es leute die sagen der
soll dann aus seinem job raus der soll
gekündigt werden dann wird beim
arbeitgeber angestellt und das ist ein
riesenproblem was wir auch angehen
müssen aus meiner sicht und das dass das
geht so nicht darum schluss sein
und es sind ja glaube ich zwei weitere
punkte noch die die leute wahnsinnig
machen das eine ist dass die kritik an
den maßnahmen die an sehr man ja sehr
vernünftige viele gründe für einzelne
sachen sind ziemlich pauschal als rechts
apostrophiert wurde also wer das
kritisierte war irgendwie ein rechter
waren sportler waren spinner also hat
von anfang an die proteste eigentlich
stigmatisiert so dass für sehr viele
normale nicht sportler nicht spinner
nicht nazis
richtige repräsentations lücke
entstanden ist er sie fühlten sich bei
keiner partei so richtig aufgehoben wenn
sie mit der afg nicht so gerne was zu
tun haben wollten vor bei der fdp ein
bisschen aber die ist jetzt natürlich
sehr auf regierungskurs oder oder
zahnrad eingeschwenkt können froh sein
dass sie kubicki noch haben und
ansonsten war es einfach schwierig also
dass genau dieses also man man sagt dann
lieber gar nichts also bevor man jetzt
rechts ist erhält man über den mond
allein da ist und das andere war hat ja
eine sehr monolithische front also viele
unserer kollegen müssen wir jetzt
vielleicht hier in dieser runde nicht zu
selbstkritisch sein aber es ist doch
wirklich ein ziemlich starkes
regierungssprecher syndrom unter unter
journalisten aus du brauchst normal ist
ja auch inhaltlich gar nicht stimmte
also eine der größten impfgegner
klientel kommen aus dem ökologischen
bereich die ohnehin auf homöopathie und
heilpraktiker setzen und immer schon
befremdet haben mit mit chemischen
arzneimitteln und impfungen auch also
das gab's also lange vor corona dass es
in bestimmten milieus sind einen
krisenabwehr dagegen gab die sind aber
ganz gewiss nicht rechts und dann hat
man einfach übersehen oder als als
typisch konservatives linken bashing
betrachtet wenn man da auf die
einigermaßen
zivilisiert auf die homöopathie freaks
eingedroschen hat das ist schon eine
komische geschichte also aber das große
problem was dahinter steht ist natürlich
ein in einer freiheitlichen gesellschaft
einen sich selbst organisierende
konformitätsdruck der dazu führt dass
wenn du nicht ganz fit bist rhetorisch
und hier irgendetwas rausrutscht du ganz
schnell an die wand genagelt wird obwohl
er einfach nur fragen hast sorgen hat
bedenken und hast das recht ungelenk
ausgedrückt und das betrifft corona das
betraf aber damals auch die migrations
krise das betrifft ganz in ganz starkem
maße die ganze gender thematik wurde
sagt irgendwie du findest das komisch
mit diesem sternchen und dann ist man
bis man den trans feind und wir haben
früher mal das hat irgendwas mit der
transportbranche
dass das ist eigentlich ganz bizarr
obwohl man einfach als normaler mensch
vor sich hin lebt und am ende sagt man
sich dann hältst lieber den mund kriegst
du musst wieder debatten und die globes
sind auch zum teil sehr militant
rhetorisch hat auch ein super stichwort
da sind wir wieder beim
erwartungsmanagement aber ich glaube
tatsächlich wir haben ein zunehmendes
problem mit der linksaußen agenda
unserer bund bundesinnenministerium
nancy faeser also erst ist sie
aufgefallen mit irgendwelchen
fragwürdigen äußerungen zur
demonstrationsfreiheit oder zu messenger
diensten dann kam raus dass sie für ein
magazin einer wirklich linksextremen
organisation publiziert hatte und statt
dann zu sagen okay leute ich hab das
vielleicht falsch eingeschätzt ich würde
das nicht mehr so machen und
linksextremismus ist neben
rechtsextremismus und islamismus und
religiösen extremismus ein problem das
wir bekämpfen müssen statt deswegen hat
stattdessen hat sie wieder nur von
rechtsextremismus geredet und so getan
als gäbe es da kein problem dann hat sie
eine flüchtlingspolitik vorgeschlagen
die in ihrer eigenen behörde von den
sicherheitsbehörden als gefährlich
erachtet werden wurden das kann dann
raus weil sie eben illegale migration
befördern würde und den schlepperbanden
das leben leichter macht würde und so
kann man keine gute innenministerin sein
als innenministerin ist man zuständig
dafür unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung wird zu schützen und da
muss man über jeden zweifel erhaben sein
frau fischer scheint auf dem linken auge
blind zu sein und so jemand kann nicht
innenministerin sein so jahr kann die
verfassung verfassung nicht schützen zu
dieser einsicht muss sie selber sehr
sehr schnell kommt und ansonsten muss
auch olaf scholz handeln denn das geht
einfach nicht an der spitze dieses
wichtigen ministeriums
na ja wo sich zugegeben bei fräsern noch
schlimmer dass ihr demonstrationen
eigentlich verbieten wollte oder auch
nicht mehr den sinn weil demonstrationen
zu sehen schienen die in kronach zu
haben was ich ganz klar sagen muss ist
der das ist jetzt ein etwas salopp
formuliert aber der linksextremismus hat
eine bessere lobby als der
rechtsextremismus eigentlich alle formen
von extremismus falsch und wir wollen
sie als gesellschaft nicht aber ich
finde linksextremismus ihr wirkt ja
immer noch so eigentlich nehmen die
leute noch so hin und ich glaube dass
das ganz ganz wichtig ist es ja auch ein
ganz scharfe abgrenzung zum
linksextremismus brauchen und das ist
mir manchmal ist es bei mir finde ich
einen gesellschaftlichen diskurs nicht
der fall unbedingt und ich habe ja diese
formulierung kampf gegen rechts schon
angesprochen es ist ja gar keine frage
wir müssen rechtsextremismus bis aufs
messer bekämpft so das ist eine riesige
gefahr das ist auch zu nehmen hat
todesopfer auch in der eigenen partei
wurden landrat der cdu ja auch chancen
von rechtsextremen also das geht einem
selber auch nach muss man sein geld auch
man uns überhaupt nichts belehren dass
wir das massiv bekämpfen müssen genauso
wie religiösen extremismus aber auch
linksextremismus denn es stärkt ja auch
wieder andere extremisten wenn wenn das
wenn der staat stabilisiert wird und die
leute sehen da wird mit zweierlei maß
gemessen das ist ein riesenproblem auch
bei den grünen übrigens dass da oft das
auge zugedrückt wird auch bei
vorfeldorganisationen von denen
vielleicht kommen wir da auch noch
darauf zu sprechen und deswegen wir
brauchen eine klare kante und wenn
gerade die innenministerin darum spur
bild auf dem linken auge blind ist und
nicht klare kante zeigt dann kriegen wir
dann probleme und das wird sich auch auf
andere bereiche ausweiten deswegen da
muss man handeln da kann man nicht
einfach aussitzen und da ist im zweifel
auch der kanzler gefragt aber ich habe
ja vor allen dingen gestalten sie ist
die verfassungsministerien und sie ist
glaube ich auch juristin wenn ich es
richtig weiß und sie haben es
angesprochen dieser dieser erste tweet
der skin sinngemäß für hass und hetze
gibt es die polizei und hass und hetze
sind gar keine straftat ist tatbestände
also da kommt noch nicht die polizei man
darf in diesem land hessen ist nicht
schön aber darf man und hetze gab es ein
straftatbestand in der ddr das war
staatsfeindliche hetze und boykott hetze
das kann man verfolgen mit dem
strafrecht aber mich hat einfach
gewundert dass sie in dieser
juristischen materie nicht fit ist und
dann sich zu einer meiner
gefühlswallungen hingibt und sie einfach
so raus posaunt das schon sehr seltsam
die polizei kommt gleich gar nicht zum
einsatz der staatsanwalt also das ist
seltsam ich fand es vor allen dingen
sehr schwierig also dass tatsächlich
innenminister in der bundesrepublik
deutschland die versammlungsfreiheit
das hat mich sehr erschüttert aber muss
man sich mal ein bisschen dann auch
wieder noch zurück in die zeit der
großen koalition gucken also ich glaube
warum wir beim rechtsextremismus so
empfindlich sind in deutschland ist klar
das ist einfach alles so risch gegründet
und das ist auch zurecht irgendwie also
in unserer dna dass das das ist völlig
in ordnung so aber das auf der anderen
seite nicht ordentlich hingucken ist
natürlich nicht in ordnung und es gab ja
auch die ganze zeit unter kanzlerin
merkel also dieses programm demokratie
leben das im familienministerium
angesiedelt waren das ist ständig
aufwächst ich weiß jetzt nicht die
aktuelle zahl aber waren schon zuletzt
glaube ich so 130 millionen euro im jahr
und da hat ja die die cdu damalige
familien müssten kristina schröder mal
sehr tapfer versucht zu sagen wir wollen
eigentlich gerne und bekenntnis also
einfach von allen die da was kriegen da
sind die verschiedensten initiativen ist
aber sehr stark linkslastig das muss man
wirklich sagen und zwar zum teil auch
linkslastig mit abgrenzungsproblemen in
den docks also radikalen rand würde ich
mal sagen und da hat sie ja versucht
also die darauf festzulegen dass sie
sich doch bitte zur freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung bekennen
wenn sie also mittel aus diesem programm
beziehen wollen was ich jetzt nicht so
eine schreckliche zumutung fände ehrlich
gesagt und das wurde ihr ja dann also
sozusagen sehr angekreidet und als
reaktionär naiv und dumm und ich kann
mich nicht so richtig doll erinnern dass
in frau merkel frau schröder so richtig
verteidigt hätte da wobei die cdu ja
erst das 1 geführt hat dass man eben
diese klausel unterschreiben muss wenn
man öffentliche gelder bekannt dass man
sich zum grundgesetz bekennt aber das
war von wesentlich despotischen bruder
hat war also aus meiner sicht die beste
familienministerin der letzten zeiten
aber sie hat das auf jeden fall sehr gut
gemacht aber das war ja eine der fall so
wie man in einer koalition mit der spd
und das war ganz klar die spd fordern
die wollen das ganz abschaffen und wir
haben dann zumindest noch in diese
förderbescheide reingeschrieben so um
eine gewissen abschreckungseffekte zu
erzielen aber das bräuchten unbedingt
und das ganze wiederum hat schlagseite
der bundeszentrale für politische
bildung da sind ja auch parteien und
über ministerien und so weiter ist man
da vertreten im kuratorium und so weiter
das ist da vorkommnisse gab wo man sagt
dieses wichtige neutrale diese instanz
ist mit fragwürdigen artikel mit
äußerungen unterwegs das geht einfach
nicht und dann müssen auch parteien da
muss auch die cdu mehr machen wenn sie
die möglichkeit dazu also ich stimme dem
zu gebrauchen eine ganz klare abgrenzung
nach rechts aber auch eine klare
abgrenzung nach links und ich muss sagen
als unternehmerin ich beobachte dass er
alles mich nerven ja diese ganzen links
rechts kämpfe die wir haben und von
einer innenministerin wie der liebe
nancy wünscht mir einig dass sie sich
ihren job macht das heißt sie ist
eigentlich dafür verantwortlich dass die
kluge einwanderungspolitik macht keine
an wanderung in unsere sozialsysteme
sondern wirklich danach schaut dass wir
hier nach deutschen auch fachkräfte
bekommen weil das es mit eines der
größten sorgen die wir als unternehmer
momentan haben und darüber sollten wir
diskutieren über ihr aufgabengebiet und
diese aufgabe die sie hat weil wie
gesagt das ganze thema links rechts wir
brauchen die abgrenzung rechts ist
genauso schlimm wie links und das sollte
eigentlich klar sein und dann sollte
jetzt wie gerade eine innenministerin
sollte ihren job machen bin ich der
meinung gerade in der migrationspolitik
ist allerdings das programm der ampel
auch sehr schwierig also das muss man
schon sagen da wird einerseits
der sogenannte spurwechsel versucht das
heißt ich kann mich zunächst auf meinen
asylstatus berufen wenn der nicht klappt
dann kann ich einen job annehmen und
dann kann ich als arbeitsmigranten
probieren wir haben in den letzten
jahren gesehen das obwohl mehr als zwei
millionen menschen gekommen sind die
fachkraft lücke gewachsen ist dh es sind
nicht die gekommen die die lücke
schließen und wir haben etwa eine
million hartz 4 bezieher mit
ausländischen pass die meisten in den
schutzstatus also sollen eigentlich
wieder zurück dürfen auch nicht arbeiten
das andere was die ampel jetzt
einrichten möchte ist dass es reicht per
eidesstattlicher erklärung seine
personalien anzugeben also all das mit
den weggeworfenen papieren was wir
bislang hatten das wird dann quasi
legalisiert und
das schafft migrations anreize in der
mitte europas und betrifft natürlich
alle umliegenden länder auch die
plötzlich zu transitländern werden und
es erhöht den druck an den europäischen
außengrenzen also europa ist nicht
nur an den sonntags projekt sondern die
gerade die deutschen müssten sich dann
aber auch abstimmen mit den anderen
ländern ob die das eigentlich auch alle
wollen denn wenn menschen nach europa
kommen sind sie im schengen raum
aber deswegen sage ich ja kluge
einwanderungspolitik am besten mit einem
punktesystem aller kanada wir brauchen
einwanderung von fachkräften und da
sollte man auch wirklich drauf schauen
wie gesagt keine einwanderung in unsere
sozialsysteme und das erwarte ich auch
von einer innenministerin dass sie so
ein programm oder gelbe und setzt die
regierung auch aufsetzt
ich gehöre zu den leuten die
traditionell immer noch ein bisschen
hoffnung hatten dass man tatsächlich
einer form von einwanderungsgesetz
hinbekommen kann das richtige anreize
setzt und das dann tatsächlich menschen
die gerne hier arbeiten wollen und die
unserem arbeitsmarkt was zu bieten haben
dass die gerne kommen können vielleicht
auch etwas leichter als das bisher der
fall ist denn das ist ja dann wieder
bürokratische sogar also für eu nicht
ganz unaufwendig und dass wir
qualifiziert die jüngere menschen
bräuchten ich meine das schreit einen ja
praktisch von jedem lieferwagen aus
jedem schaufenster bei jedem wetter
überall hängen zettel mitarbeiter
gesucht und das ist ja sozusagen
qualifizierte jobs auch der fall also
dass wir irgendwie bedarf haben und dass
wir durch unsere eigene demographie
nicht mehr decken weil wir alle also in
meinem alter zu wenig kinder hatten sind
sagen dass das ist ja so insofern also
intelligenter einwanderung wäre
natürlich tatsächlich auch eigentlich
was schön ist also eigentlich was das
also diese dieses lege eine fortschritts
kollidieren sein warum nicht mal also
sozusagen schöne sagt attraktive
angebote und sowohl für menschen die
hier leben als auch für menschen die
hierher kommen wollen aber dann muss man
eben klar definieren was dann gefangen
ist
ja und ich glaube also ich glaube das
ist auch deswegen nicht passiert weil es
daher eine ideologie gibt die dahinter
steht also diese open borders ideologie
ist ja tatsächlich das sagen viele bei
spd und grünen dass es im grunde gar
keine grenzen mehr geben sollte und dass
migration über grenzen hinweg ungeregelt
einfach stattfinden können sollte das
ist gerade von der basis her gibt es da
viel druck von der grünen jugend und so
weiter und das ist natürlich eine ganz
gefährliche ideologie weil wir damit
auch da sind wir wieder beim punkt
vertrauen die menschen merken natürlich
dass das nicht funktionieren kann es ist
im grunde genommen auch ein stück von
stückweit gnadenlos wenn man auch leuten
damit hoffnung macht die sich auf den
weg machen und sich damit in große
gefahr begibt und dass das kann nicht
funktionieren aber das ist eben das
problem das dahintersteht
es ist bis jetzt natürlich doch und
erinnert aber auch nochmal an den satz
wir schaffen das zum thema integration
der natürlich sagen viele menschen auch
sehr verstört hat das waren nämlich
diejenigen die das schaffen mussten in
ihrer schule auf ihrem schulhof wo ihre
kinder drangsaliert werden wenn sie die
butterbrote im ramadan essen und was
weiß ich was alles wenn ich also die
kanzlerin hat das sehr
menschenfreundlich und oben hin gesagt
und sozusagen aber ja konkret und sehr
wenig angeboten wieder in integration
die dann eben auch robust ist und die
menschen etwas abfallen lang konkret
aussehen sollte und das mussten
irgendwie andere leute regeln und wie
schlecht das zum teil funktioniert kann
man sich in den quartieren die davon die
damit viel zu tun haben sehr lebendig
ansehen nicht insofern es ist es
kann ihre kritik an einem feser da jetzt
absolut nachvollziehen nur gerade weil
er bei der einwanderungs thematik er hat
glaube ich frau merkel uns da auch eine
hypothek eine vertrauensverlust hypothek
hinterlassen
also das wäre bei der integration auch
noch große herausforderung haben ist
klar in hamburg ich war letztens bei so
einer israel mahnwache in der hamburger
innenstadt die war auch wurde mal
angegriffen antisemitisch und dann sind
wir da hingegangen haben solidarität
gezeigt wenn sie da stehen denn da haben
wir innenstadt nur neben der israel
fahne kommt alle fünf minuten jemand
vorbei und macht irgend eine blöde
bemerkung
beschimpft ein komisch an bedroht mit
körperlichen gesten das habe ich in
meinem alter nie so erlebt das muss man
wirklich so machen und das ist immer so
dass das das sozusagen aus einer ecke
kommt und dass man sieht dass es uns
auch integrationsprobleme und das ist
ich bin da völlig d'accord soweit gehört
aber auch nach 2015 war es auch die
union die die einwanderung die illegale
einwanderung massiv reduziert hat und
die zahlen unter das niveau was ist
vorher war wieder zurück sind konnte er
diskutiert nach einer kleinen mini
unterbrechung ganz lebendig weiter und
es warten noch zwei sehr spannend ihm
auf sie bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich ein lauter krach und
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren für den a8 leben trotz der
schlagzeilen machen mein name ist wieder
fit
so nicht
herr jörges retten seit august aber
niemand von den politischen parteien
traut sich zu sagen ja das wollen wir
einfach nur freiheit diese grün-roten
der damen führen hochtrabende debatten
über die rettung des weltklimas und um
die füße russen die ratten das thema ist
viel zu wichtig um es nur der ard zu
überlassen lasst den leuten soll man den
spaß wir sehen da etwas was eigentlich
fatale ist in der politik bei den
journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade hat viele meinungen zu führen und
sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
sein und das tragen eines konnten zum
manko leider konnten
dennoch ist übrig anooraq trainer
ausgesprochen beliebt ist ich hatte
meinen fall um eine sache immer bekommt
wer kümmert sich darum niemand ist hier
der ganz kleine auch darüber sprechen
ganz einfach nicht der hat nämlich
richtig ist die konnte mädchen nicht
begraben nur noch vierter noch
[Musik]
keine wunde sendezeit vergoldung
dementsprechend geht es direkt weiter
geschwind mitreißender ja ich habe mich
gewundert was der klimaschutz plötzlich
alles möglich macht aber zuerst robert
habeck der wirtschaftsminister der jetzt
auch für klima zuständig ist und er hat
gesagt ja wenn wir windräder bauen
wollen dann müssen wir auch mal die
rücksicht auf den rotmilan
beispielsweise der gern geschreddert
wird von solchen rotorflügel müssen ein
stück weit zurück stecken wir finden
jetzt eine ganz raffinierte lösung wir
verrechnen die roten milan bestände
einfach europaweit und weil die
franzosen viele atomkraftwerk haben da
kann der roten landal ungestört brüten
und bei uns wird halt gewechselt also
rot wieder in schutz artenschutz
eigentlich ein hohes gut zurückgestellt
auf baumfällungen für windräder sind
viel einfacher
das finde ich bemerkenswert gegen all
die jahre nicht und scheiterte meistens
auch an den grünen jetzt hat die
bundesumweltministerin gesagt die hat
sie wieder ungehorsam gehört dazu und
wenn sich junge menschen mit
sekundenkleber auf den straßen
festkleben diese blockieren für einen
guten zweck gegen
lebensmittelverschwendung oder gegen den
klimawandel dann ist das schon okay also
hat sie hohes verständnis für das finde
ich interessant das waren unangemeldete
illegale sitzblockaden mit hohem aufwand
für die polizei die mit sonnenblumenöl
und verdünnung mühsam mit einem pinsel
die am kreaturen da wieder von der
straße kratzen mussten im wahrsten sinne
des wortes und der verkehr gestaut es
gab riesenärger bis hin zu problemen mit
sanitäts autos die nicht durchkamen und
eine bundesministerin hat verständnis
für illegale aktionen liebe
spaziergänger aufgepasst ziviler
ungehorsam gehört dazu sagt die
bundesumweltministerin würde ich mir mal
merken für die nächste für die nächste
zeit und dann stellen wir jetzt als
klima botschafterin für die
klimaverhandlungen aller welt die
greenpeace-chef hinein die hatten auch
noch einen etat von 6 milliarden für
internationale klimaprojekte in
schwellenländern das finde ich eine
tolle sache ich hoffe nur dass sie
einfach die greenpeace agenda nicht im
amt einfach fortsetzt sondern auch noch
ein stück weit deutsche interessen mit
im blick behält
sie ist amerikanerin und muss jetzt mit
hochdruck eingebürgert werden all das
ist plötzlich möglich weil es der
klimaschutz verlangt also ich bin
gespannt was uns da an kreativen ideen
von der ampel regierung noch alles
nächster zeit bevorsteht ja und ich
glaube tatsächlich also volle zustimmung
und ich glaube dass das eines der
größten probleme ist da sind wir auch
wieder beim thema vertrauen in die
demokratie und in unsere institution
wenn die leute merken da gibt es
verschiedene standards und dieser satz
der zweck heiligt die mittel ist einer
der gefährlichsten für die ganze für den
ganzen gesellschaftlichen diskurs in dem
sinne und wir erleben einfach dass der
doppelte standards angelegt werden wenn
völlig anders mit friday is for future
demonstrationen umgegangen wird als mit
mit denen ich inhaltlich nichts zu tun
habe aber als mit querdenker
demonstrationen die leute sehen das ist
im grunde genommen ist eine
demonstration und die muss eben
geschützt sein und da kann man nicht
anders mit der ein umgehen als mit der
anderen genauso lässt man freilich
verfügt als organisation dinge
durchgehend die anderen organisation die
längst dann nicht mehr existieren
könnten antisemitismus-vorwürfe mit cdu
der verfassungsschutz in hamburg hat
schon früh auch von der unterwanderung
von linksextremen organisationen da
gewarnt das sind alles sachen die würden
bei jeder anderen organisation extrem
kritisch diskutiert werden und da sind
sicher viele dabei mit guten motiven
aber man darf eben nicht sagen nur weil
die für die richtige sache stehen aus
aus der sicht des betrachters jeweils
ist alles in ordnung das geht nicht ich
mache mir vor einigen sorgen tatsächlich
dass das was jetzt an ungutem gelernt
wurde in der korona krise nach dem motto
lebensgefährlich rechtfertigt also
weitestgehende grundrechtseingriffe dass
das jetzt als modell genommen und
übertragen wird auf klimafragen denn ich
weiß gar nicht wann das in unserer
politik sozusagen demokratisch
beschlossen worden ist dass die
klimakrise jetzt sozusagen das größte in
deutschland in deutschland und von
deutschland zu lösende problem ist aber
offenbar sehen das viele so auch viele
publizistische kollegen sehen das
inzwischen so und es wird durchaus
diskutiert in den unterschiedlichen
kreisen also von kirchen bis zur
nationalakademie leopoldina und auch bei
den grünen und auch robert habeck hat
das in seinem letzten buch zumindest
angedeutet dass man im prinzip also wenn
das denn eigentlich dramatisch ist wenn
es bei der klimakrise jetzt also ähnlich
um leben und tod geht wie bei corona man
natürlich überlegen kann ob man
grundrechte auch weiter einschränkt und
da sehe ich sozusagen also dem die
größten und gefährlichen gefährlichsten
zusammenhang zu dem was jetzt lernt
werden worden ist was dringend wieder
verlernt werden muss bevor es also
unmittelbar weiter angewendet wird dann
auf die klimakrise denn dann können wir
uns wirklich von demokratischen
verhältnissen mittelfristig
verabschieden dann erst heißt es immer
not kennt kein gebot und was man da
wählt oder beschließt es dann egal also
für mich sind es ja wirklich
ideologische grabenkämpfe die wir hier
veranstalten aber es ist wie man es hat
schon begonnen mit fritz fischer
ich habe das natürlich bei unseren
unternehmen auch live miterlebt die
radikal teilweise auch vorgegangen wurde
unternehmer bashing betrieben wurde
obwohl wir als familienunternehmen schon
viele jahre bevor es überhaupt freie so
fischer gab investiert haben in neue
klimaschutzmaßnahmen in neue
technologien aber ich muss auch an
dieser stelle nochmal sagen ich
diskutiere wirklich viel über das klima
das klima dem klima ist es relativ egal
wo dieser co2 ausgestoßen wird ja es ist
ein globales problem und wir brauchen
globale lösungen und was wir machen in
deutschland wir verfolgen einen
nationalen alleingang und wir machen
unseren wirtschaftsstandort kaputt damit
deswegen lassen uns doch globale
lösungen anpassen wir hatten damals
dieses großartige projekt desertec
desertec hatte das ziel wüstenstrom zu
generieren in afrika wohlstand zu
schaffen arbeitsplätze dort solaranlagen
zu bauen grünstrom zu exportieren da
könnten wir in europa in der ganzen welt
diesen strom auch nutzen was ist
passiert das ganze ist am politischen
willen gescheitert dieses projekt gibt
es aber jetzt auch wieder und ich würde
mir tatsächlich wünschen dass wir dieses
projekt auch vorantreiben weil was
machen wir wir schalten unsere
kohlekraftwerke ab unsere atomkraftwerke
wir machen uns abhängig eigentlich von
anderen ländern und das kann doch nicht
die lösung sein wir müssen wirklich
jetzt globale lösungen entwickeln plus
und top natürlich ein gutes instrument
ein marktwirtschaftliches den
europäischen globalen emissionshandel
das müsste man wirklich anpacken um die
klimakrise zu bewältigen und nicht hier
in deutschland klein klein irgendwelche
von der straße zu ziehen also es ist
wirklich und das aus unternehmersicht
immer wir machen unseren
wirtschaftsstandort kaputt und müssen da
jetzt wirklich was unsere lage effektiv
und wir schlagen uns effektive
instrumente auch noch selbst aus der
hand wir haben im kohleausstieg haben
wir festgelegt dass deutschland sich an
keinerlei kohletechnologie auf der welt
mehr beteiligt wir wurden bei letzten
reise der kanzler südafrika gebeten ob
wir die 85 prozent kohle strom erzeugen
hoch dreckig zehnmal so viel co2 dass
wir dort filteranlagen zur verfügung
stellen um das zu filtern da könnten wir
den co2 ausstoß mindestens halbieren den
südafrika hat nein wir haben uns ja
geschworen wir beteiligen uns an
keinerlei kohletechnologie auf der welt
mehr die kanzlerin musste dankend
ablehnen und hat dann darauf verwiesen
vielleicht können die briten oder
franzosen helfen das wäre wirklich
erschreckend finde wenn wir uns
anschauen momentan sind in asien
606 100 und wir diskutieren über
fahrradfahren e auto auf die straße das
ist doch verrückt unser anteil sind zwei
prozent am weltweiten ausstoß das müssen
wir uns bewusst machen und wir schlagen
uns als unternehmer herum wir
investieren unser kapital in technologie
freundliche maschinen et cetera wir tun
und machen aber wir machen mit dieser
politik die wir verfolgen unseren
wirtschaftsstandort familienunternehmen
sind da übrigens absolut führend also
nun in den kleinen maßstäben natürlich
die den den benefit auch haben von
solchen klima schonen den maßnahmen das
ist wirklich zum teil grandios was was
kleinere betriebe also 500 mitarbeiter
und etwa in der größenordnung der
leisten von solarpanelen bis geothermie
und das fällt jetzt nicht so groß auf
aber es ist ein riesen beitrag und das
ist schon aus eigeninteresse weil man
einfach kosten spart wenn man ökologisch
wirtschaftet das sieht aber keiner und
stattdessen gibt es dann immer wieder
proteste und wir müssen in der mensa
mindestens drei vegetarische tage
einführen um das weltklima zu regieren
bleiben bei dem motor unseres landes der
wirtschaft und des geht mit seiner
roeser ja ich habe heute das thema
wettbewerbsfähigkeit mitgebracht denn
fakt ist deutschland verliert jeden tag
an wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseren
wirtschaftsstandort verliert jeden tag
an wettbewerbsfähigkeit und ich vertrete
über sechseinhalb 1000 familien
unternehmen darunter 1500 junge
unternehmer in deutschland und wir
machen uns große sorgen weil genau diese
themen nicht angepackt werden wir
brauchen einen neuen turbo im thema
klimapolitik in der digitalisierung wir
brauchen infrastruktur wir haben das
enorme problem des fachkräftemangels wir
haben eine untersuchung eine befragung
bei unseren familien unternehmen
durchgeführt zwei drittel der
familienunternehmer sagen dass die
größte sorge der fachkräftemangel ist
also wir müssen doch da wirklich jetzt
mal anpacken das erwarten wir auch von
seiten der jungunternehmer von der ampel
das erwarten wir auch von der fdp um
ihren neuen freunden die sie jetzt haben
wir müssen wirklich schaue ich mal
christian lindner hat er jetzt den
ersten schritt in richtung startups
gemacht das ist gut aber wir brauchen
auch weitere verbesserungen der
rahmenbedingungen wir brauchen weniger
bürokratie wir brauchen ein tag dieser
für fachkräfte wir brauchen
unterstützung dass wir hier in
deutschland entlastet werden als
unternehmen und das ist wirklich eine
priorität und nicht gerichtet an die
union würde ich mir tatsächlich auch
wünschen dass diese selbstbewusster
auftritt dass sie auch konkrete
forderungen richtet an die regierung und
dass sie auch wirklich klartext redet es
ist eine große chance für union und fdp
zusammen hier auch stark die
wirtschaftspolitischen themen
voranzutreiben das finde ich haben sie
vollkommen recht und gleichzeitig legen
sie den finger in eine eine weitere
wunde die glaube ich wieder zu tun hat
mit dem vertrauensproblem es ist
vermutlich sogar in der fdp und in der
union inzwischen und sagen zu wenig
wirtschaftliches know-how vertreten
durch menschen die mit ihrer biografie
dafür tatsächlich stehen man kann viel
lesen und man kann sich viele
untersuchungen angucken und und kann
versuchen betriebe zu besuchen und sich
zu informieren aber das ist dann doch
immer an gelernt das wissen so zu sagen
leute die wirklich aus dem bereich
selber kommen und die nöte und sorgen
kennen die müssten sie eigentlich auch
direkter in die politik einspeisen kann
was wir aber beobachten und das gilt für
die union auf jeden fall wenn ich die
letzte untersuchung die ich dazu gelesen
habe nicht völlig falsch erinnere ist es
gibt eine ganz starke tendenz zur selbst
rekrutieren bei den parteien das heißt
immer öfter wird der mitarbeiter des
abgeordneten dann abgeordneter das ist
im ersten moment wahrscheinlich auch
plausibel weil der versteht viel davon
gemacht hat er das vielleicht besser als
alle anderen bewerber von außen aber wie
soll da sozusagen der der familie der
bericht eine verantwortung und auch noch
was anderes zu tun hat sozusagen
überhaupt sich diesem diesem ritual
unterwerfen dagegen ankommen und dann
diese zeit im parteien verbringen wir
brauchen irgend eine intelligente lösung
wie sie entweder ihre leute oder das
wirtschaftspolitische know-how stärker
also wie sie das besser in vier
versuchen wir ja das problem ist wir
haben tatsächlich viele berufspolitiker
und wenig wirtschaftskompetenz in der
politik und wir jetzt als auch als
verband die familienunternehmer die
jungunternehmer wir reden uns den mund
fusselig wir kritisieren nicht nur
sondern wir erarbeiten auch
lösungsvorschläge tragen die der politik
vorgeben ihnen unsere lösungsvorschläge
wie es laufen kann damit die wirtschaft
auch weiter in zukunft entlastet wird
aber manchmal habe ich das gefühl das
geht da rein und da raus leider und es
wird die dann kommt nicht richtig machen
und das ist problem wir als unternehmer
sind macher umsätze und das fehlt mir
tatsächlich in der unternehmer in die
politik gehen
friedrich merz ist ja nun gerade das
gegenbeispiel und wenn ich mir anschaue
wie auch der neue bundesvorstand der cdu
zusammen gesetzt da sind auch einige
wirklich treffen nehmen
auch kein unternehmen aufgebaut und
geführt ja aber hat viel
wirtschaftserfahrung ja an seinem
lebenslauf gesammelt das muss man glaube
ich schon sagen und ich glaube auch ganz
wichtig ist der punkt also ich könnte
jetzt auch sagen beschwert euch nicht
bei mir ich hab cdu gewählt ja im moment
ist es ja jetzt nicht die cdu die im
bund regiert leider aber ich glaube dass
auch der punkt infrastruktur ausbauen
noch ein ganz wichtiger ist und da muss
ich sagen bin ich auch überrascht wie
schnell die fdp umgekippt ist als erstes
fiel die
technologieoffenheit beim elektroauto
hinten rüber jetzt werden auch projekte
aus dem bundesverkehrswegeplan wieder in
frage gestellt und so weiter also ich
weiß nicht ob diese partnerschaft mit
der fdp mit der ampel fdp so gut
funktioniert aber wir haben uns das
vorgenommen ich glaube es auch teil der
inhaltlichen neuaufstellung der pflanze
wieder erfolge
nein absolut das heißt auch die fdp darf
jetzt nicht umkippen muss festhalten an
dem t muss auch proaktiv themen setzen
marktwirtschaftliche
wirtschaftspolitische themen aber ich
glaube auch dass die union unglaubliche
chance er hat jetzt mit solchen stimmen
von außen kritisch zu beobachten laut zu
sein klartext zu sprechen weil die
kombination aus union und fdp kann
wirklich etwas bewirken für die
wirtschaft habe ich große hoffnung dass
gerade unsere nur eine einzige frage du
hast ja gerade unseren finanzen bisher
christian danach paar links begleitet
wie war dein eindruck von ihnen also
geht er jetzt das ist dann immer nach
vorne also ich finde es klasse dass er
gerade in diesem bereich start-ups und
gründer thum unternehmer wirklich auch
macht also er hat sich wirklich dieses
projekt angenommen er ist nach paris er
hat dort einen star eu startup fonds mit
frankreich gegründet und es ist ein
gutes signal ein starkes signal das
brauchen wir auch weil das thema ist er
wirklich in deutschland wir feiern das
unternehmertum zu wenig wir brauchen
mehr gründer und ersetzt wirklich ein
starkes signal und das ist wirklich auch
mal machen das finde ich gut und positiv
das wird ja jetzt alles viel besser
werden denn wenn die mode um sich greift
das man lobbyisten direkt auf seine
kosten dann wird demnächst bestimmt der
bdi-chef oder andere verbände werden da
ganz groß zum tragen kommen und oder
sieben
mal interessant mit jenny jenny morgen
oder übermorgen die wurde er von
annalena baerbock jetzt auf diese
position gehoben aber eigentlich ist
doch die position von annalena baerbock
außenministerin zu sein wir haben doch
wirklich so viele probleme gerade
draußen er eigentlich sollte sie sich
doch darum kümmern wenn ich dachte
robert habeck ist ein fürs klima und
wirtschaft verantwortlich und dass sie
jetzt auf einmal also ich bin ja wieder
das außen die außen klimaverhandlungen
hat ausdrücklich sie sich ins als
kompetenz ins haus geholt das ist ein
ganz cleverer schachzug der die die
grünen gemacht haben sie haben nahezu
alle klima kompetenzen bei sich
gebündelt vor allem die auf europäischer
ebene das fällt vielen nicht auf ist
auch relativ unerotisch weil die
brüsseler dinge schwer zu durchschauen
sind alles was man dort fest zonen kann
zum beispiel bei der taxonomie
führt dazu dass es später in nationales
recht umgesetzt werden muss oder aber
direkt auf unser wirtschaften wirkt also
wenn wir in brüssel durchsetzen eine
bestimmte solar quote dann kommt die
irgendwann zu uns hat nur niemand
bemerkt weil wenn er in brüssel was
beschlossen wird kriegt dass keiner mit
und fünf jahre später müssen wir es
einführen das ist relativ clever und man
spielt dann über wandel in brüssel und
das haben sich die grünen ganz gut
gesichert und frau berbalk hat die
internationalen aber die kompetenzen das
macht ja noch schlimmer also wenn die
lobbyistin sogar noch ins zuständige
ministerium kommt und quasi also direkt
im rahmen ihres lobbyverein stan politik
machen kann ja auch dazu das jetzt
irgendwie noch die staatsbürgerschaft
man muss man aber vor allem das ist ja
auch eine organisation die zuletzt vor
allem durch kriminelle und hoch
gefährliche aktionen aufgefallen und sie
sollte aufregen dass leute aufhören dass
wir im reichstag abzuseilen
oder farben auszuschütten in berlin das
käme nicht gut in ihrem staatsamt das
andere problem ist aber wenn jemand
dergestalt lobbyist tisch vor geprägt
ist bei diesem klima verhandlungen auf
internationaler ebene ich weiß nicht wer
sich das mal reingezogen hat die gesamte
kopenhagener klimakonferenz mitgemacht
das nicht vergnügungssteuerpflichtig das
ist ein teppichhandel ohne ende und da
kommt es darauf an sich auch nicht über
den tisch ziehen zu lassen von anderen
ländern nur weil klima einfach eine
tolle sache ist und da habe ich ein
bisschen bedenken denn es ist ein hohes
maß auch an eigeninteresse dabei dass
man versucht jedes halbe prozent co2
sich anzurechnen über permafrostböden
über stäube die über der sahara
aufgetrieben werden und nach
lateinamerika waren im co2 senken
aufforstung jeder möchte sich möglichst
viel an rechnen und da muss man eben
auch als unterhändler ganz klar sagen
dass sich nicht andere leute alles an
rechnen können und wir sind dann
diejenigen die es bezahlen wenn die
tonga inseln untergehen machen wir schon
machen wir auch zu recht aber es muss
ein fairer anteil seien alle mitmachen
und diese stoffe verhandeln darf nicht
durch einen gp klima ist eine tolle
sache wir geben alles mentalität da habe
ich ein bisschen bedenken dass deutsche
interessen da unter die räder kommen
wenn so eine hochkarätige lobbyisten
dann sitzt was die fachkompetenz im
bundestag betrifft ist übrigens ganz
interessant wenn man ein paar jahre
dabei ist und sich mit abgeordneten
unterhält man stellt immer wieder fest
dass diejenigen die einen beruf gelernt
habe oder außenberufen bundestag
gekommen sind ein ganz anderes
politikverständnis haben vier
pragmatisch auf viel detaillierter und
und realist aber deswegen ist es auch
die möglichkeit geben für quereinsteiger
als ich kenne unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer die wirklich sagen würden
also ich tue das auch jetzt krempeln die
ärmel hoch und ich gehen die politik
gemacht so schwierig macht die
parteiführung tatsächlich das wollen wir
sagen das machen wir und das fördern wie
es funktioniert nur wenn es von oben
gefördert wird und solange es noch einen
einzigen normalen bewerber in jedweder
man eingibt wird er sagen das ist gar
nicht nur durch wir haben ja noch eigene
tolle leute also wir machen doch jetzt
hier keinen platz freuen wir beenden die
sendung heute dem ruf nach ja vielleicht
unternehmer in der politik danke dass
sie eingestellt haben und schön aber
auch wir sehen uns dienstag wieder um
20.15 haben sie doch einen schönen abend
tschüss bis bald
[Musik]